le fameux biscuits aux pépites de
chocolat on le fait avec du beurre ou
avec de la margarine signaux c'est très
simple de biscuit moelleux avec des
brisures de chocolat
tout ce que je déteste le chef jérémie
jean baptiste cuisine des biscuits avec
du beurre de la margarine et de la
tartinade la différence va vraiment se
faire au niveau du goût la
nutritionniste et spécialiste en
marketing
isabelle marquis compare le beurre et la
margarine
on a vraiment affaire à deux produits
qui sont très différents plusieurs
égards qui ont quand même pas mal de
similitudes le beurre est un très vieux
produits en fait selon plusieurs
historiens le bar existerait depuis
environ cinq mille ans et nous viendrait
des peuples nomades d'asie dans du
beurre on part d'un ingrédient laitier
soit le lait ou la crème les fabricants
on doit d'ajouter un maximum de quatre
autres ingrédients du sel en colorant
des cultures bactériennes et d'autres
matières solides
romer du lait dans la margarine on a
fait un tout autre histoire
on parle d'un mélange de graisses et ou
d'huile végétale
il faut que ces gros là ne soit pas
laitiers dans les ingrédients
obligatoire on parle d'âge ou de
vitamines a et vitamine d ensuite des
fabricants vont ajouter des colorants
des arômes des émulsifiants des agents
de conservation et autres additifs de
ton qu'il s'agit d'un produit beaucoup
plus transformé la margarine aurait été
inventé vers 1869
suite à une demande de napoléon iii de
trouver une alternative au bar qui se
conservent vrai mieux et qu'ils seraient
moins jeanne la margarine d'origine
était composé de graisse de boeuf de
lait et de complètement différent de ce
qu'on retrouve sur le marché aujourd'hui
auparavant lors de la fabrication de la
margarine en hydrogène l huile végétale
pour la rendre solide
on s'est rendu compte que
l'hydrogénation créer les méchants gras
trans et que les gras trans industriels
sont extrêmement dommageable pour la
santé cardiovasculaire
ce qui fait que depuis déjà deux ans au
canada les gras trans industriels qui
proviennent de l'hydrogénation de
l'huile sont interdits dans les aliments
transformés
alors toutes les margarines qu'on
retrouve sur le marché aujourd'hui sont
fait d'huile végétale non hydrogénée
la majorité des margarines au canada
sont fabriqués avec un mélange d'huile
dans la base et le canola pour rendre la
texture de la margarine plus ferme
on ajoute de l'huile de palme de
palmiste ou de coco ces huiles la
contiennent entre 50 et 90 % de gras
saturés l'huile d'olive et d'avocats
sont aussi de plus en plus présente dans
les margarines ce qu'il faut lire
clairement sur l'emballage ce niveau à
l'huile d'olive et à l'huile d'avocat
c'est avec de l'huile d'olive et avec de
l'huile d'avocat
autrement dit il y en a très peu ça n'a
aucun impact ou aucun effet sur la
valeur nutritive du produit pour
connaître le pourcentage de chaque type
d'huile
il faut regarder sur le couverte mais
attention le produit n'est bien sûr pas
composé uniquement que d'un mélange
d'huile suffit de regarder la liste des
ingrédients pour s'en apercevoir les
gens l'impression que la margarine
contient moins de matières grasses que
le beurre
quel beau mythe mais détrompez vous
c'est complètement faux beurre et
margarine contient un minimum de 80 % de
matière grasse
c'est le type de gras qui diffèrent dans
le cas du beurre on parle de 60 % de
gras saturés et 40% est saturé alors que
du côté de la margarine
c'est 10% saturé et 90% insaturés et on
sait que les gras insaturés sont
davantage favorable à la santé générale
et notamment la santé cardiovasculaire
certaines études récentes ont démontré
que les gras saturés qui proviennent des
ingrédients laitiers ne serait pas aussi
nocif pour la santé cardiovasculaire que
ce qu'on a longtemps cru il reste la
recherche à faire pour pouvoir confirmer
le tout mais attention
peu importe le type de gras la quantité
de calories est la même pour le beurre
et la margarine pour le sodium c'est la
même chose à quantité égale la margarine
est comparable au beurre salé
dans certains cas on voit le mot
tartinades ou de margarine qui est
utilisée c'est le cas entre autres du
produit par l'insee si la raison étant
que ya certains ingrédients qui ont été
ajoutés qui ne cadre pas dans la
définition d'une margarine à savoir dans
ce cas ci la protéine de poids
côté marketing et communication très
intéressant a comparé le beurre de façon
générale reste assez simple et
traditionnelle dans sa présentation
on reste dans un univers qui est quand
même assez classique et il le barça ce
sans comparaison
par contre du côté de la margarine c'est
le festival des allégations il y en a à
perdre plusieurs minutes à l'épicerie si
on veut soumettre les faire tout ce qui
est indiqué sur les emballages
attention de ne pas tomber dans le piège
de croire que la margarine et 100%
végétale c'est faux la plupart d'entre
elles contiennent en effet une petite
quantité de produits ou sous produits
laitiers c'est le cas en particulier de
la marque becel et ça nous donne une
fausse impression aussi que le produit
est 100 % végétal ce qui me paule ka
alors pour moi cette stratégie là est
vraiment plus de l'opportunisme
marketing sur une tendance qui est très
forte en ce moment que de favoriser des
aliments à base de plantes
mais est ce que ça nous aide vraiment à
faire un choix à mon avis non ici on a
un produit 100% végétale de legrand mais
qui utilise l'appellation beurre vegam
le mot barils n'ont pas le droit de
l'utiliser
le bar est un terme qui est réglementée
et qui réservait aux aliments qui sont
fait à 80 % de matière grasse laitière
ce qui n'est pas le cas de ce produit
chez legrand on nous dit qu'il utilise
volontairement de mon beurre car le goût
et la texture de leurs produits sont
très semblables et c'est ça le nerf de
la guerre pour beaucoup de personnes
le goût du beurre est difficile à égaler
dans bien d utilisation certes on peut
utiliser en pâtisserie la margarine ou
le beurre j'ai pu constater qu'avec la
margarine la pâte à biscuit était
relativement souple pour la tartinade
une patte un petit peu plus dur et avec
le beurre quelque chose de beaucoup plus
rigide on peut tous y cuire des aliments
avec chacun d'eux mais attention le
point de fumée
c'est à dire le moment où les gras et
les protéines commence à se dégrader et
très bas autant pour la margarine que
pour le bas ce ne sont pas des produits
qui sont à privilégier pour de la
cuisson
à haute température pendant plusieurs
minutes c'est vraiment pas souhaitable
les gros se transforme rapidement ça
nous amène des composés nocifs pour la
santé qu'on ne souhaite pas c'est de ne
pas aller trop fort et de bien gérer la
température de sa castrol pour la haute
température
les huiles de canola et de tournesol
sont à privilégier
mais sûr nous rôti au beurre ou de
margarine
j'ai envie de vous dire si votre
principale utilisation du beurre c'est
d'en mettre sur votre style matin et que
vous en remettez pas un gros carré sur
chaque boutique vous prenez squat de
l'un ou de l'autre
prenez ce qui nous fait plaisir
[Musique]